[Musique]
ballet smac attention non alors vous
savez ce que je voudrais qu'on fasse
vous êtes seul au monde vous êtes tous
les deux non mais non et maxime à un
moment tu vas essayer de ramasser et on
va voir ce qui va se passer je prendrais
ouvrage attention non mais là on est en
retrait et qui tempère maximum son père
c'est monsieur gainey à l'éval la
mayonnaise gagner alors attention on met
un autre solo c'est parti pour ce choix
le droit de le dire même pas les
condamner
[Musique]
attention attention on rame est
exactement un timing
ils ont vingt secondes pour savoir s'ils
vont s'embrasser ou pas faites vous
plaisir oublier les caméras
oubliez votre vie ailleurs et là aussi
il ya une seule boule qui compte c'est
la boule à facettes
j'étais vous je vous dis attention c'est
parti
maxime tu peux tenter à capucine tu peux
tenter de chacun peut tomber à n'importe
quel moment fille dans mes attentions
merci à vous et mènera tôt à l'autre ils
ont même exactement mais pour l'instant
et maxi je sais pas si c'est réussi le
drop en tout cas je les sens mieux parce
que c'est le seul mec a une fille fait
tu veux mettre un terme
attention c'est parti vous êtes seul au
monde mais fait comme s'ils venaient à
l'émission strip étaient pas obligés a
été obligé de tuer un art witty fait que
son casque si tu as eu quatre ou six cas
une généralité par titre kpc d'être une
rigueur j'avais choisi rexie vous plaît
capucine vous avez choisi matière est ce
que c'est votre style bah oui c'est le
plus beau 1 0
non parce que royaume des aveugles le
borgne est lourd la pj est ce que c'est
votre style ouais bon train
votre destin est entre vos mains
la championne tchèque ce que vous voulez
si l'amour on tape à la porte
qui sait c'est l'amour qu'est ce que tu
veux l'amour écoute j'aimerais montrer
chez toi avec un grand a
comment div oui j'ai des problèmes
dorsaux attention ma chérie
maxime c'est parti on y va
[Rires]
ouais c'est vrai honneur
ces 4 5 ap chaud ce qui brille oui bah
oui madame vivriers alors les chéris
franchement comme ça c'est ça c'est un
bout d'os saint louis avant c'était pas
le mec il se fait embrasser il applaudit
d'amendé contre m
est-ce que alors je vous pose une
question est ce que vous êtes
célibataire maxi je suis célibataire
scellement pas sur lui la vie va vite
que son ombre
je suis célibataire vous vous en êtes où
quatre fois non quoi alors moi je suis
prêt soit vous êtes pousse ballon alors
prise dans le sens électricité non pas
les 200 ou quoi mais c'est pas vrai nous
a dit attendez attendez chier ou plus on
se calme donc vous êtes en couple
ouais donc ça n'est pas possible avec la
personne non alors est ce que vous êtes
amoureuse attendez c'est possible qu'au
rythme être que c'est un couple libre on
sait très bien bravo en tout cas merci
non mais c'est vrai et j'espère que moi
je vous verrai bien ensemble je trouve
que c'est un mec bien qu'il vous
faudrait comme ça moi comme maxime un
mec qui est sain d'esprit prend au corps
propre propre propre propre sur les i et
de rompre partout voilà ça allait on va
bien sûr qu'on reconnaisse et fils delon
mais au moins maintenant chaque fois le
fait sa croix bayard s'est plus fait sa
rentrée qui n'était pas le fils c'est
pas le fils de gucht est libre ses deux
fils bayrou non c'est qui ces fils
devenu alors revenons maintenant à les
faire trembler est ce que c'est le fils
de quelqu'un
oui
la concession est ce que c'est 10 de
quelqu'un de connu a dit la vérité
non l'état verra non surement la mélodie
mancelle avait juré sur la tête je vais
sur la plaine de finale en live les
chéris j'espère que la bourse frappera
votre porte
en tout cas sachez que je serai toujours
là si vous n'avez besoin de rien de le
dire